i swear to god before shauna knight's
first date i was so nervous i took two
tequila shots and sang defying gravity
are you serious i swear to god camila
cabello needed a little liquid courage
the first time she hung out with her now
boyfriend shawn mendes this is my best
self the 24 year old singer made the
reveal during the latest installment of
carpal karaoke with james corden
alongside her cinderella co-stars adina
menzel and billy porter who followed up
with some very important questions
set the scene for this where are you
going on this you're in the shower okay
so shawn and i have been talking for a
couple weeks now like oh my god like i'm
so excited to see you like i can't wait
to kiss you like all that stuff right
okay and so obviously like that there's
just a lot of stakes yes you know before
this thanksgiving for the first time i'm
like oh my god do i kiss him when i see
him like i don't know but you guys
already had the duet together right you
already had to do it together we were
friends but we like we weren't together
right um no one has seen each other
naked yet no camila explains that she
was hanging out at home with her family
when shawn decided to stop by
my dad is there i'm like
pour me two tequila shots like just like
do it and to really calm her nerves she
pulled out her secret weapon and i just
sang
defying gravity
[Applause]
yeah that's camilla with adena aka the
original elphaba from the musical wicked
belting the iconic song
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and we're here like years later it's so
cool fast forward to 2021
[Music]
and the couple has been together for two
years e.t spoke with camila in 2019
shortly after the pair went public with
their romance i do obviously like i love
him
in
uh he's my boyfriend way but i've always
loved him as just i just love him you
know and in 2020 sean teased that they
could be end game is she your forever
person like do you talk about
an engagement one day do you talk about
it yeah
absolutely she's been one of my best
friends since i was like 15 years old so
i don't know at the same time i know
we're really young so i don't want to
jump like insanely fast but
i think when you find your person you
feel and you know that you found your
person and it seems sean is not only
camila's person but also her biggest fan
she revealed during carpool karaoke that
he actually helped her prepare to play
cinderella did you used to run lines
with sean did he help you with this at
all um we did run lines together for a
brief period in uh how was he though was
he judgey
no because i you know i my ex-husband i
love him but he was a little too judgy
with me when i used to
um run lines and then i got very
self-conscious no sean was
self-conscious running the lines with me
and he wasn't even
and when it came time to promote the
musical the cuban triple threat gushed
over sean's support every step of the
way he's the best and i think we're
really supportive of each other and you
know always want to see each other like
he was there for the whole beginning of
it and
was so supportive and uh
yeah i'm lucky i have awesome people in
my life
[Music]
you